what the hell
come on get me out of here what's up I'm
Kristen Stewart and I'm Ella balinska
I'm Will Smith and I'm Martin Lawrence
I'm Emma Mackey and I'm Oliver Jackson
Cohen I'm Tom Holland and I'm Jake
Gyllenhaal hey I'm Chris I'm Tessa I'm
Noah Centenary I'm on a condor I'm Oscar
Isaac and I'm Ethan Hawke hi there I'm
Jody coma here I'm Ryan Reynolds and
this is First Impressions First
Impressions impressions
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
no idea
no idea I was supposed to be a hyena I'm
supposed to be here
I was supposed to be here I thought I
was an actual person
oh wow um is it like
[Applause]
look at the makeup
just keep doing it because I don't want
to answer because I want you to keep
doing this
flies and swims it's a bird
okay we'll also Raptor yeah because
that's what they do didn't they they do
the chicken oh ostrich no
that was actually a better impression
bird it's a bird obviously okay well
there's little wings because you need
your wings Little Wings small bird yeah
yes
well I think I'm Gonna Change career now
wow that's fun
Mickey Mouse
uh I love you
wait what hold on Elmo no dear God no
he's flying are there always songs about
rainbows Kermit yes wow I love you
almost pregnant
this is good oh oh Kermit the frog
Kermit the Frog was that good I feel a
little bit confident this piggy helped
um
yeah
a duck a pigeon yeah
a pigeon yeah yeah a crowd
oh
my God it doesn't sound anything alive
yeah I'm just so lucky I said duck
[Music]
don't don't do that to me
um
Donald Trump
you're an animal
giraffe
this is whoever did this is hilarious
yeah just
I'm gonna do it for the fun of them
um
mm-hmm
I can't believe I'm reducing my career
to this are you okay are you okay it's
an animal please it's an animal please
okay
no I'm not gonna do this it's really
embarrassing I'm gonna stop that oh yeah
a pterodactyl
a
lion Wolverine
[Applause]
[Applause]
I mean you know
okay I don't know if this is what they
sound like but
mandrel monkey or gorilla or chimpanzee
oh It's gotta be in the in that family
it's not chimpanzee gorilla
it's a baboon oh baboon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um I'm an animal
[Music]
I don't know like what makes that noise
an octopus no
um space
okay so it's like
[Applause]
and then it's like
Dolphins there you go oh my God now you
know what a good impression that is
Dolphin yes yep
I used to freak my mum out when I was
young and I go oh my God
no I feel like
um
oh God some of that was deeply
embarrassing but you can use all of it
again I don't know how to impersonate
him cheat one of the greatest guys Hugh
Jackman oh I don't know how to do it
it's not Hugh Jackman Barack Obama oh my
God how do you impersonate him he sort
of talks a bit like this oh yeah Eddie
likes to throw it back he can have high
points